STEVE: BRIAN OVER TO YOU.
BRIAN:  THANKS MEANWHILE A TEXAS
SHERIFF IS ORDERING HIS DEPUTIES
TO STEP UP THEIR VIGILANCE ON
ROADS AND HIGHWAYS NEAR THE
BORDER AFTER HIS CALLS FOR
ASSISTANCE FROM THE WHITE
HOUSE TO COMBAT THE SURGE OF
MIGRANTS GO UNANSWERED.
BEAR COUNTY SHERIFF SALAZAR
WRITING AN ORDER TO PRESIDENT
BIDEN LAST MONTH, "I CAN NOT
STAND BY AND LET MY FELLOW LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS CONTINUE TO
LOSE FAITH IN YOUR LEADERSHIP
AND ADMINISTRATION, PLEASE HELP
US.
" SHERIFF SALAZAR JOINS US NOW.
YOUR ASSETS ARE BEING SHIFTED
ELSEWHERE FROM THE BORDER, AND
NOW YOU GOT TO BE BORDER AGENTS
TOO, RIGHT?
>> WELL WE’RE CONCENTRATING OUR
EFFORTS ON THE HIGHWAYS AND I
WOULDN’T CALL IT BORDER AGENTS.
WE’RE CONTINUING OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT MISSION BUT WE ARE
HAVING TO CONCENTRATE MORE ON
THE HIGHWAYS BECAUSE OF WHAT’S
GOING ON DOWN SOUTH.
BRIAN:  WHY, ASSETS BEING PUSHED
ELSEWHERE?
>> WELL FROM WHAT WE UNDERSTOOD
, THEY ARE PULLING A
LOT OF BORDER PATROL ASSETS DOWN
SOUTH TO THE BORDER WHICH IS
UNDERSTANDABLE.
THEY ARE DEALING WITH A SEA OF
HUMANITY IN THAT HUMANITARIAN
CRISIS, AND THEY ARE DOING WHAT
THEY CAN, BUT WITH THAT BEING
SAID IT’S LEAVING THE STATE
VULNERABLE IN OTHER AREAS AND
WE’RE NOT DOING THAT.
BRIAN:  WHAT ARE YOU SEEING
COMING THROUGH THAT NEVER USED
TO COME THROUGH BEFORE?
>> IT’S AN EVERY DAY THING BUT
WE ARE CERTAINLY SEEING MORE
DRUGS COMING UP NORTH, WE’RE
GOING TO BE SEEING MORE GUNS AND
STOLEN VEHICLES HEADING DOWN
SOUTH, AND SO LOOK IT’S JUST UP
TO US TO STEP UP AND FILL THAT
GAP.
BRIAN:  YOU’RE NOT TALKING ABOUT
DEMOCRAT OR  REPUBLICAN.
YOU JUST WANT SOMETHING
EFFECTIVE FROM WASHINGTON.
WERE YOU SURPRISED YOU DIDN’T
GET ANY ANSWER FROM YOUR LETTER?
>> WELL, I MEAN, LOOK I KNOW
THAT THE PRESIDENT’S
ADMINISTRATION IS BUSY WITH
WHAT’S GOING ON IN AFGHANISTAN.
I KNOW THEY’VE GOT OTHER THINGS
GOING ON ON A WORLDWIDE SCALE.
I CAN’T EVEN IMAGINE AND MAKE NO
MISTAKE ABOUT IT I DO SUPPORT MY
PRESIDENT, BUT WITH THAT BEING
SAID THAT’S WHY I FEEL THAT IT’S
MY PLACE TO ASK FOR MORE, IN
TALKING TO SOME SHERIFFS FROM
DOWN SOUTH AT THE BORDER,
REPUBLICAN AND DEMOCRAT THEY
FEEL LEFT BEHIND.
THEY FEEL LEFT OUT, AND SO I’M
ACTUALLY FLYING DOWN SOUTH LATER
THIS MORNING WITH DPS TO GO GET
A LOOK AT IT.
I’LL PROBABLY BE MEETING UP WITH
ONE OF THE LOCAL SHERIFF’S DOWN
THERE, MARTINEZ, TO SEE WHAT WE
CAN DO TO HELP.
BRIAN:  SHERIFF WHAT ABOUT YOUR
MAYOR AND YOUR GOVERNOR?
>> WELL LOOK THE GOVERNOR, I
CAN’T SAY THAT I AGREE WITH HIS
POLICY, LOCKING UP A LOT OF
THESE UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS IN
THE STATE PRISON BECAUSE WHAT
THAT’S DOING IS CAUSING A
BACKLOG IN THE PRISON SYSTEM
WHICH IS IN TURN AFFECTING MY
JAIL POPULATION AND MY DEPUTIES
ARE WORKING OVERTIME TO KEEP UP
WITH THE JAIL POPULATION SO IT’S
A DOMINO EFFECT SO THAT’S WHY I
SAY, BORDER PROBLEMS ARE BEAR
COUNTY PROBLEMS BY DEFAULT AND
WE’LL DO EVERYTHING IN OUR POWER
TO HELP.
BRIAN:  JUST GIVE THEM A HAND,
SHERIFF IS DOING EVERYTHING HE
CAN WITH THE STAFF HE HAS BUT
HE’S BEING OVERWHELMED AND IT
AFFECTS EVERYONE, NOT JUST